some of the earlier ideas at digital
money simply took the form of a public
ledger you know you start off with money
you have a list of who owns how many
coins and then people call in and say I
hereby transfer so many coins to
such-and-such and you then update the
ledger now of course in real life proper
money actually works like that it's just
that the banks don't keep an infinite
publicly visible history of all the
transactions but Bitcoin keeps
everything publicly visible forever the
basic idea behind Bitcoin is that you
have got thousands of people called
Bitcoin miners who compete to find the
next cash in something called a
blockchain and a new hash is found about
every ten minutes so what happens is
that hundreds of people who want to do a
transaction say I want to pay you a
tenth of a Bitcoin which is about 25
pounds or so pay for lunch or a taxi
ride or whatever then what I do is I
sign a transaction saying that I pay you
25 pounds and that gets collected
together with hundreds of other
transactions that people want to do
around the world and Bitcoin miners work
on it how they work on it is the lookk
for a random number which together with
the last hash of the block bot chain and
the batch of pending transactions will
have a certain property and this
property is found only about one time
every 60 million million million
attempts so you get thousands in fact
millions of computers around the world
working to try and find the next hash
with this special property by trying the
existing blockchain plus all the
transactions in the queue that are
waiting to be processed and eventually
every 10 minutes or so some lucky person
puts up his hand and say found it and
when that happens he gets 25 bitcoins so
that's the reward for that person for
finding that particular hash the
blockchain is a list of all the
transactions that have been done with
Bitcoin back since the first transaction
in 2008 or 2009 and it's punctuated
with hashes and each hash binds together
the transactions that happened up to
that point in time and so anybody can
look back over all the blockchain and
can trace the origin of any particular
Bitcoin when it was mined right when it
was awarded as a you know as a prize to
a miner who found an appropriate hash
and everybody who spent it or subdivided
it or did something else with it since
then so it's an open ledger and the
history of every single coin is visible
to all what you basically do is you adds
to the blockchain basically one hash at
a time so you start off with the last
hash plus all the transactions that
you've swept together into a pool to add
to the chain and then there's the hash
that you find at the end it's also worth
saying that miners tend to work in pools
and at present there are three large
pools which distribute the work to tens
of thousands of people who then beaver
away happily trying to find the next
hash and when the reward comes through
right then each of these mining pools
will win a reward about once every half
hour or so they then share that owed to
the miners who work for them so what
you've ended up with is a system whereby
people combine bit Bitcoin mining
equipment they can plug it in they can
sign up to a mining pool and they get a
return on their investment
just as if they'd put money in the bank
or the return is at present slightly
better if you're actually paying for
electricity half of all the return that
you get on your investment is going to
have to go to pay the electricity bill
there's a significant problem coming
down the line because next year about a
year from that is slightly under a year
from now the reward for finding a
Bitcoin is due to fall from 25 bitcoins
for a successful hash to 12 and a half
now when this was set up the inventor
decided that in order to prevent
inflation the number of bitcoins that
you would get would fall over all times
the amount of work that you had to do
pair Bitcoin would increase until
finally the amount of Bitcoin in
circulation will be stable now this
means that from about October next year
if you are doing Bitcoin mining on a
fully commercial basis then every dollar
that you spend
on electricity will return only one
dollar in expectation and bitcoins
rather than two dollars at the present
time so there's no way for you to recoup
the capital cost of your equipment
unless of course you can place your
equipment in places where electricity is
very cheap or encourage dorm rooms where
it's free and eventually College Dean's
are going to start putting in
electricity liters and what then happens
to Bitcoin so is this part of the way
that Bitcoin works is that these these
rules have been set up already they're
over sitting about time these things
happen well at present the Bitcoin rules
will set up by the anonymous guy who set
the system up in 2008 and they're
maintained by the people who maintain
the Bitcoin software and so long as they
agree on what the software should do you
have consensus but if they were to
disagree and farc the system into two
separate universes then that would have
huge consequences just like for example
if if Greece had left the Europe there
would have been all sorts of trouble to
mop up nobody knows for sure who wrote
bit time the the person who claimed
authorship Satoshi Nakamoto appears to
be a pseudonym and various people have
been found who might have been him what
we do know is that the first Bitcoin
transaction was made with hal fini who
was a cypher pump a cryptographer and a
quarter who could definitely have
invented this and come up with it and he
unfortunately died of mortal neuron
disease a while ago so we can't now ask
him whether it was his handiwork
he did deny it at the time but in any
case somebody unknown who may have been
how give us this amazing and fascinating
system and as for where it goes in the
long term the answer is I don't know the
the blockchain is a truly wonderful
technical innovation it doesn't quite do
what people like cypherpunks originally
thought it would nearly create a stable
anonymous currency that was beyond the
reach of governments
and my feeling is that it hasn't quite
found a killer application yet if you
think of the internet for example back
in the mid 1990s people thought that
bringing the Internet to the home would
be absolutely great for basically
delivering video to the home so
something like you get from your
favorite video rental service or your
PVR was reckoned to be for people that
use the internet flow and of course that
turned out to be not its real
application the real application of the
Internet as everybody knows is
disseminating photographs of cats so
what will be cats for a Bitcoin we don't
know and whoever figures that out might
stand to make quite a few shillings
in the back of them they put little
mobile phones so that whenever you use
this terminal it would text your card
and PIN you start getting the voltage
representing your six drifting a bit nee
looks like a certain